C'est incroyable, c'est
absolument incroyable.
C'est vraiment indescriptible.
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave.
Et là, tout le monde bosse, sauf nous.
C'est le même principe physique
qu'à bord de la station spatiale,
c'est aussi le même principe physique
qu'à bord d'une cabine d'ascenseur
qui tomberait du 250ᵉ étage.
C'est pour ça que ça dure que 30secondes,
mais ça permet de réaliser
plein d'expériences scientifiques.
Bonjour à tous, je suis Léo Grasset
de la chaîne YouTube Dirtybiology
et on est ici avec Brut pour
aller faire un vol Zero G.
(Éternuement)
L'avion qui est derrière moi
est un véritable laboratoire
dans lequel les chercheurs peuvent
venir, amener leurs expériences
et tester des hypothèses dans
des conditions de pesanteur
qui sont plus faibles que sur la planète.
Donc là, sur ce vol, il y aura
principalement des chercheurs.
C'est un vol vraiment à but scientifique.
Et on va faire le brief sécu
parce que le vol en Zero G, c'est demain.
- Vous volez tous là, ou...?
- Oui!
- Ah oui, jeudi?
- Moi je vole jeudi.
D'accord.
Donc déjà, avant toutes les paraboles,
nous on fera un petit rappel.
00:01:22,190 --> 00:01:25,214
On va vous demander de fermer
vos poches, ranger les badges,
les tournevis ou les petits
outils que vous pourriez avoir,
pour éviter qu'ils ne se mettent
à voler en cabine.
Ces vols-là étaient utilisés par la NASA
pour commencer l'entraînement
des astronautes,
et notamment ceux qui
sont allés sur la Lune.
Les vols paraboliques scientifiques
ont commencé dans les années80.
Le but était tout simplement d'embarquer
des expériences scientifiques
de manière tout à fait comparable
à ce qu'il se passe en orbite
dans la station spatiale internationale.
Donc vous voyez là, tout se passe
bien, très bien, il est sage.
Sauf que là, la sangle finit par glisser
et à la fin il y a un petit pic négatif,
et vous voyez le résultat est immédiat.
Pic négatif = on part au plafond.
Le plafond il est à 2m20, 2m30,
heureusement il y avait le matelas
qui était en dessous,
donc voilà, on veut surtout pas ça.
On vous demande d'être vraiment
sérieux et d'être sécurisés.
(Applaudissements)
On a fait un gros briefing de sécurité
pour savoir quelle est la conduite à tenir,
quel est le matériel accepté à bord.
On se retrouve en apesanteur
pendant 20secondes,
et après on subit deux fois son poids
pendant deux fois 20secondes.
Donc ils nous préparent un petit
peu, à l'avance, à ce qu'on va vivre
pour qu'on soit le moins surpris possible
et qu'on puisse profiter
au mieux de l'expérience.
Donc là on est dans l'enceinte
de recherche du vol Zero G.
Ici, c'est là où toutes les expérimentations
scientifiques sont faites.
Elles ont chacune leur espace.
Les chercheurs seront
tenus par des sangles.
Tout le monde doit être
tenu par des sangles ici.
Parce que sinon les gens vont se tomber
les uns sur les autres avec les paraboles.
Les murs, le sol et le plafond
ont été matelassés
pour amortir les chocs.
Parce qu'on a le corps
qui monte naturellement
et on n'a plus aucun contrôle
sur nos mouvements.
Toutes les expériences
scientifiques ont été matelassées
au cas où il y aurait des trucs
qui tombent dessus, pour les protéger.
Et ce qui est vraiment intéressant
dans cet outil de recherche,
finalement c'est un avion de recherche,
c'est qu'il aide à préparer
le futur de l'exploration spatiale.
Il y a beaucoup d'expériences
qui sont faites ici,
qui ont un lien direct avec la
station spatiale internationale.
Donc les préparatifs sont terminés.
On a pu voir un peu quels
types d'expériences
il y aurait demain en apesanteur.
Ça va être vraiment,
vraiment hyper intéressant
et on est tous très très excités.
Donc là on va aller se coucher assez tôt,
parce qu'on décolle assez tôt demain aussi.
T'as vu mon t-shirt comment
il est trop cool?
- Bonjour!
- C'est pour se faire piquer.
- Oui, eh bien venez.
Vous m'avez dit Grasset Léo.
Vous avez déjà volé?
Non.
- Première fois?
- Oui, ma première fois.
Donc je vous fais la dose de base,
standard pour les hommes.
Cette injection c'était de la scopolamine,
c'est un sédatif qui permet de
ne pas ressentir de nausées.
Parce que le problème de l'avion,
c'est que notre cerveau
va voir quelque chose
et notre corps va ressentir quelque
chose de complètement différent.
Et ces deux informations contradictoires
peuvent vraiment provoquer une
sensation d'extrême malaise.
C'est vraiment juste
pour diminuer l'activité
et la sensibilité de
notre tube digestif.
Donc là on est à 10minutes
de la première parabole.
Les chercheurs sont en train
d'allumer leurs expériences.
Ce qu'il va se passer c'est que
dans 10minutes l'avion va
prendre beaucoup de vitesse,
il va commencer à monter
à 45degrés d'angle.
On va gagner à peu près 2500m d'altitude,
pour arriver au sommet de la parabole
où là on va sentir l'apesanteur.
- Vous avez votre ceinture, messieurs?
- Oui, c'est tout bon.
J'ai défait à fond.
Ça commence.
OK.
- 30fois ça on va faire?
- Oui!
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave, laisse.
Vas-y tranquille.
Oh la descente!
C'est incroyable,
c'est absolument incroyable.
C'est vraiment indescriptible.
Tous tes sens sont complètement perdus.
Tout ce que tu connais n'existe plus.
Et vous allez voir mon
visage qui va descendre
et le sang qui va descendre
en bas de mon corps.
Voilà, ça y est, c'est parti, on monte.
On est en train de prendre 2500m
d'altitude à une vitesse incroyable.
Vous allez voir la déformation
sur mon visage,
tout mon visage est attiré vers le bas.
Deux fois plus quasiment que d'habitude.
Et là, bientôt, on va arriver
au sommet de la parabole,
et au sommet de la parabole
on est en apesanteur,
on est en véritable chute
libre avec l'avion.
Ça y est, à chaque fois c'est un... waouh.
À chaque fois c'est vraiment
un phénomène incroyable.
Et on se retrouve vraiment
en perte totale de sensations.
Ça y est, je suis la tête à l'envers.
De toute façon, à l'envers,
à l'endroit, il n'y a plus aucune...
Attention.
On recrée à l'intérieur l'apesanteur,
c'est-à-dire que tout va flotter.
C'est le même principe physique
qu'à bord de la station spatiale,
c'est aussi le même principe physique
qu'à bord d'une cabine d'ascenseur
qui tomberait du 250ᵉ étage.
Nous, par rapport à la cabine, on flotte.
Mais l'avion, lui, pendant sa trajectoire,
au bout d'un moment,
va descendre pour reprendre
une trajectoire normale.
C'est pour ça que ça dure que 30secondes,
mais ça permet de réaliser
plein d'expériences scientifiques.
Nous, ça ne se voit pas, parce que tout est
fermé, mais on est en train de cabrer,
les pilotes sont en train
de cabrer, tirer sur le manche,
l'avion prend une trajectoire
très verticale.
Là, on subit 2g, deux fois
le poids de notre corps,
et ensuite, une fois qu'on va être
arrivés vraiment le nez en l'air,
on va injecter l'avion sur la parabole,
et là tout va commencer à flotter.
Alors là, c'est maintenant que
ça se passe, et là tout décolle.
Alors, normalement, si c'est zéro,
on reste exactement au même niveau.
Si c'est un peu positif on monte,
si c'est un peu négatif on descend.
Et là, c'est exactement la même chose
que dans la station spatiale,
sauf que ça dure que 30secondes.
Donc là l'avion redescend
la tête vers le bas.
On va reprendre une trajectoire
horizontale et, à ce moment-là,
quand on reprend une trajectoire
horizontale, on tire sur le manche.
C'est comme en voltige,
on prend un peu des g,
on est écrasé par
deux fois notre poids
pendant cette manœuvre,
jusqu'à ce que ce soit terminé,
qu'on reprenne un vol horizontal,
et là on est dans les conditions
pour en recommencer une nouvelle.
Toi, ça te rappelle des sensations
que tu pouvais avoir
dans la navette spatiale?
Ah oui oui, c'est exactement
les mêmes sensations.
La différence, c'est qu'ici
ça dure que 30secondes.
La différence aussi c'est qu'ici,
malgré le fait que le pilotage
soit très très précis,
on est parfois un peu
positifs, un peu négatifs,
donc ça va monter, descendre.
Dans la station, pendant 6mois, ça bouge
pas du tout, on est calés sur le zéro.
Il y a un truc qu'il faut savoir,
c'est que le mal de l'espace,
ou le syndrome d'adaptation
spatiale en anglais,
est principalement dû au système
vestibulaire de l'oreille interne
qui est complètement désorienté.
En fait, on a trois demi-canaux
qui nous donnent des informations
sur l'orientation de la tête.
Et on a aussi des otolithes,
donc c'est des petites pierres...
Ces otolithes indiquent la direction
du sens de la gravité,
de l'accélération de la gravitation.
C'était une expérience qui est
hyper intéressante à deux niveaux.
Le premier est sensoriel, c'est
extrêmement intéressant de ressentir
toute une nouvelle gamme
de choses, de sensations.
Notre oreille interne n'a jamais
vécu ça et c'est vraiment fou.
Un avion peut être
transformé en laboratoire
pour pouvoir donner des expériences
qui font de la micropesanteur.
Donc c'est vraiment, à tous les sens, sur
tous les aspects, une super expérience.